ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى هذه التغطيه
المستمره لتطورات في السودان نتابعها بكل
تفاصيلها تداعياتها وتاثيراتها كذلك الصحه
السودانيه اعلنت ارتفاع عدد قتل
الاشتباكات بين الجيش والدعم السريع الى
460 فضلا عن اصابه اكثر من 4000 اخرين اما
طرق الخروج من السودان فما تزال كما هي
الرعايه الاجانب الى بورتسودان اما
المواطنون السودانيون فيسلك اغلبهم طرقا
محفوفه بالخطر وتحت ظلام دامس هربا من
القتال
[موسيقى]
يمكن اصعب لحظه التفكير في الخروج ووسط
اصوات انفجارات عنيفه وسط اصوات رصاص قرر
بانه يبعد باولاده عن اماكن النزاع بين
القوات المسلحه وبين قوات الدعم السريع
ومش كان بيقولوا في هدنه لكن حتى الهدنه
كان في حرق واضح ليها يعني الواحد يتمنى
انه الحرب ينتهي وانه يرجع الامن والامان
للسودان
وفي اخر هذا التطورات اجلت الامم المتحده
المئات من موظفيها العاملين في السودان مع
عائلاتهم واوضح مراسل العربيه في السودان
ان عمليه الاجلاء تمت عبر ميناء بورتونا
العمليه صعبه احد الوقت اكثر مما كان مخطط
لها ولكن العمليه
جئنا مع هذه القافله من الخاتون لبورت
سودان
وانه حاليا
الاطفال والعائلات على السفينه الفرنسيه
تركوا الحرب وراءهم بحثا عن طريق للخروج
من السودان الاف الاشخاص من عشرات
الجنسيات غادروا للوصول الى بر الامان
وعبر وجهات مختلفه كثيرون وجدوا ما تسنى
لهم من وسائل مغادره السودان بحرا او جوا
في حين لجا اخرون للطريق الاصعب بقطع
الجغرافيا السودانيه برا للدول المجاوره
مفوضيه شؤون اللاجئين في تشاد اعلنت ان
عشرين الف لاجئ وصلوا الى هذا البلد مع
توقعات بان يتبعهم مئه الف اخرون في اسوا
الحالات اما في جنوب السودان فترجح
التقديرات الامميه نزوح ما يصل الى 170
الف شخص ثلاثه ارباعهم من لاجئي جنوب
السودان الذين سيعودون في رحله نزوح جديده
لكن في بلدهم هذه المره حتى من وجدوا
دولهم او دوله ثالثه تمد لهم يد العون فهم
يعانون الامرين لمغادره السودان في رحله
محفوفه بالمشاق تليها نقاط توقف مؤقته لمن
غادروا برا الى مصر او جوا الى جيبوتي او
بحرا عبر بورسودان وصولا الى السعوديه
العربيه
اكدت
باسم الخارجيه الفرنسيه
ان باريس تدعو الى وقفه اطلاق النار
لاسباب انسانيه محضره من المواجهات
الدائره في السودان وقالت بانها قد تؤدي
الى صدمه اقليميه وازعزعه لاستقرار
المنطقه ذبح
ندعو الى وقف اطلاق النار في السودان
لاسباب انسانيه السودان كان دوله هشه على
الصعيد الانساني مع وجود نحو اربعه ملايين
نازح قبل هذه الازمه ثلث سكان السودان لهم
احتياجات انسانيه يجب تجنب حصول صدمه
اقلاميه تزعزع استقرار المنطقه وتؤثر على
الدول المجاوره مفوضيه اللاجئين اشارت الى
وجود عدد كبير من النازحين داخل السودان
اضافه الى لاجئين من الذين اجتازوا الحدود
مع تشاد وهذا سيضغط على الدول المجاوره
على الصعيد الانساني
كما قالت الناطقه باسم الخارجيه الفرنسيه
للعربيه ان عمليه اجراء رعايه معاقده بعض
الشيء وكان من المفترض ان تتم بعض الحصول
على ضمانات لاجلاء نحو 500 شخص من السودان
انها عمليه معقده ميدانيا ودبلوماسيا
لانها جرت فيما يتواصل القتال في السودان
كان يجب القيام بسلسله اتصالات تسمح
باعطاءنا ضمانات امنيه لاجلاء حوالي 500
شخص من السودان كما هو معلوم تمكنا من
اجلاء رعايانا والطاقم الدبلوماسي وايضا
اجلين عددا كبيرا جدا من الرعايه الاجانب
في السودان
هذا هو كانت رصدت مراسله العربيه الاجواء
في منطقه المعموره جنوب الخرطوم حيث يحاول
المواطنون وبعض الاجانب مغادره العاصمه
هربا من المعارك
والله ماشيين من حلفا للغاهره
هنمشي مصر
[موسيقى]
في العيش بقى في اي حاجه حتى الاندومي
الحاجه البسيطه
في الشارع من بيتنا الثاني داخل على شقتي
الرصاص
سكينه الدعامه بنص الحله الرصاص تحت كرينا
يعني امام معدوم من افراد
مسافرين الاسره كلها قريبه 20 19 29
وغير قدامي يعني
ما في امان النزوح حاليا هذه البصات
السفريه تتجه لمناطق مختلفه من
السودان يعني من الولايات وهذا الباص
تحديدا يتجه الى القاهره معي هذا الشاب
مرحبا وعليكم السلام ورحمه الله
شكلك مو مسافر انت اول حاجه
التموينيه اغراض
عندي ناس مسافرين من الخرطوم فالاضاء يعني
معلومه يعني تعلمونها جيدا كيف الاوضاع في
السودان
عدم توفر مراكز تجاريه عدم توفر خبز يعني
حتى اذا فتح ذهب
منتظرين في واحد بتاع دكان منتظرينه من
الصواح يمكن اكثر من خمس ساعات حتى يفتح
وحتى نسبه للوضع الخطا حتى لو تفتح نص
ساعه ساعه
فصعوبه يعني حتى في توفير لقمه العيش في
استغلال تام من اصحاب الباصات لان اصحاب
الباصات بعشرين لحد اسوان حاليا التذكره ب
300 يعني
بمثابه 300% او اكثر
ورافعين ارتفاع الجنوني في القصات اذا كان
البصل واقف قدامك 500 معقول يعني
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وفي تطورات السودانيه اخرى شجبل جيش
السوداني الخروقات العديده التي اقترفها
الدعم السريع للهدنه بحسب تعبيره الجيش
قال ان مجموعات الدعم السريع تواصل
تحركاتها داخل وخارج الخرطوم برقم الهدنه
حيث رصد الجيش تحركات لارتل عسكريه متجهه
من غرب السودان الى الخرطوم اضافه الى
محاوله مجموعات من الدعم السريع السيطره
على مصف الجيلي للتحكم بالوقود الجيش اتهم
الدعم السريع باستغلال الهدنه لانقاذ
موقفها العمليتي الذي وصفه بالمتدهور عبر
نشر قناصه في الخرطوم وولايه اخرى
في مقابل هذه التصريحات اتهمت قوات الدعم
السريع قوات الجيش باستهداف مواقعها قرب
القصر الجمهوري بالخرطوم وقال بيان الدعم
السريع ان هذا الاستهداف يعد انتهاكا
للهدنه المعلنه مؤكدا ان القصف العشوائيه
للجيش يهدد حياه المدنيين ورعايه الدول
الاجنبيه في الخرطوم كما اشارت قوه الدعم
السريع في بيان لها الى ان كسره شروط
الهدنه المعلنه يؤكد وجود اكثر من مركز
قرار داخل قياده الجيش واعاد الدعم السريع
التاكيد على التزامه بشروط الهدنه لفتح
ممرات انسانيه للمدنيين وللمقيمين الاجانب
اظهرت مقاطع فيديو استقبلها مستشفيات في
الخرطوم المزيد من المصابين خلال
الاشتباكات بين قوات الجيش والدعم السريع
نتابع الساعه
قال الصحفي مقداد حسن من ام درمان للعربيه
ان القصف الناتجه عن المعارك بين قوات
الجيش ودعم السريع طالع مركز اروميه طبي
واسفر عن اصابه عشاره اشخاص والحاق اضرار
كبيره بالمركز
يتواجد في منطقه
الثوره
ذكرى الاشتباكات العنيفه قبل ساعتين او
اكثر وقعت قديمه داخل هذا المركز الصحي
يمكن ان نشاهد هذه الخبيثه وهي هي بقايا
من هذه الرايه التي وقعت هذه الخليفه في
هذه المركز مركز الرومي الطبي والجدير
بالذكر ان هذا المركز يستانف العمل داخله
بالامس فيما اعلن اغلاق المركز بعد وصول
هذه الكلمه اكثر من 10 اصابات
هذه كما ترون القضاء الان
وانقطع في هذا المركز السلقي وان هنالك
بعد تماما اثراء هذه الاشتباكات التي حدثت
في الشارع
مركز الرومي هذا المركز
كبيره وهو مستنصر خاصه
[موسيقى]
المصابون الذين اصيب
وا بهذه الشظائع من هذه الخفيفه كانوا في
هذا في هذا المكان في تماما مركز الرومي
الطبيه كبيره لمختلف التخصصات تخصصات
القلب تخصصات الباطنيه تخصصات الولاده
تخصصات الموجات
الصوتيه والاشعه هذا المركز يعتبر من
المراكز المهمه في مدينه ام درمان
ومشاهدينا الى هذه الكلمه
لوزير الخارجيه الروسي متابع بالنداء الى
المجتمع الدولي قال لا نعرف الى جهود
الدول الافريقيه
لتقرير مصيره وحل القضايا الافريقيه
بمشاركه الاطراف الافريقيه بانفسها وليس
وبدون تدخلات اجنبيه
الوزير لدي سؤال يتعلق باوكرانيا
من
خططنا
هناك
اعتبارات برغماتيه تتعلق بانه لدينا مع
جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه
وعبرها ان نقوم بتطوير الصادرات والواردات
فاننا لا نحتاج الى
انجاح صفقه الحبوب لكي تشتري الصين الحبوب
الروسيه فيما يتعلق بالرساله التي تم
تسليحهم تسليمها امس الى الرئيس بوتين
فانه ليس هناك اي تسريبات لانها رساله
شخصيه من قبل الامين العام للامم المتحده
موجهه الى الرئيس الروسي واذا تم التصريب
اي معلومات بهذا الخصوص فهذا يعني ان هناك
من اجراءات
متخذه لممارسه الضغط
بدلا من الحل
وهذا كله يؤدي الى تعزيمه الوضع وعندما تم
التوقيع على مبادره
البحر الاسود
لتصدير الحبوب في العمل الماضي كان يدور
الحديث عن تصدير الحبوب والاسمده ايضا اي
امونيوم وحتى يوم امس لا احد كان يتذكر عن
موضوع امونيوم الا ان امس
قال لي الامين العام للامم المتحده ان
هناك حاجه كبيره الى الاسمده من امونيوم
على في السوق العالميه
وسرعنا ما تحولت تلك الصفقه
من
صفقه الانسانيه الى صفقه تجاريه هذا كله
يثير تساؤلات كثيره
وخلال كل هذه الاشهر نتحدث عن ذلك ونلفت
اهتمام المجتمع الدولي الى هذا الموضوع
واقل من ثلاث في المئه من اجمالي حجم
الحبوب
الذي تم نقله من الموانئ الاوكرانيه اقل
من 3% من الحبوب وصلت الى الدول الفقيره
اي اثيوبيا واليمن وافغانستان والسودان
والصومال اما باقيه اكثر من 80%
[موسيقى]
عندما كان زملائنا في الامم المتحده
يركزون اهتمامهم على الجانب الاوكراني
لهذه الصفقه الا ان
المسؤولين من الامم المتحده نسوا ان هناك
حزمه من الوثائق
وهناك جانبان الجانب الاوكراني والجانب
الروسي وهناك التزامات
يجب ان
مشاهدينا سنكتفي بهذا القدر كنا في متابعه
لمؤتمر صحفي لوزير الخارجيه الروسي سرقه
تحدث في الواقع عن التطورات وعن الازمه
التي يشهدها السودان واعتبر بان ما يحدث
في السودان ماساه كما وصف اكد كذلك وزير
الخارجيه روسيا ان تقسيم السودان من
اولويات الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وقال
ان على المجتمع الدولي عدم عرقله محاولات
حل ازمات افريقيا من دون تدخل اجنبي تحدث
كذلك فيما بعد عن الحرب في اوكرانيا نتحدث
عن العلاقه الصينيه الروسيه ولكن قد ناتي
على كل هذه النقاط في نشرات قادمه سنعود
الى متابعه التطورات الخاصه بالازمه
السودانيه كنا تحدثنا عن مصادر الصحفيه
اكدت قصف
لمركز الرومي الطبي ووقوع 10 اصابات نقف
على تفاصيل اوفى فيما يخص هذا التطور مع
نفس هذا المصدر الصحفي مقداد حسن
من اندرمان مقداد اهلا بك معنا كنت
اوفيتنا في نشرات سابقه بقصف الناتج في
الواقع عن اشتباكات بين الدعم السريع
والقوات المسلحه السودانيه نتحدث عن 10
اصابات حتى الان تؤكد لنا وتحدث لنا هذا
الرقم وماذا في تفاصيل ما حدث
نعم انا الان داخل احدى الصيدليات التي
تعتبر من صيدليات الكبيره في هذا الشارع
هنا في ام درمان ارصد لكم اخر التطورات
على مستوى الصيدليات وعلى مستوى الامداد
الدوائي داخل هذه الصيدليه
نعم مركز الرومي كان هنالك استباكات
والمواطن الاولى وكما كانوا داخل هذا
المركز شاهدوا وجوه وقوعه قذيفه داخل هذا
المركز واصيب اكثر من عشره اصابات نقلوا
الى مستشفى النوم وهو مستشفى معروف هنا في
منطقه
الان العربيه داخل هذه
الصيدليه وكما تشاهدون هنالك توافد كبير
ونسبي وبصوره يوميه على هذه الصيدليه بعد
ان اغلقت جميع المراكز الصحيه قرب هذه
المنطقه ابوابها نسبه لخطوره الوضع الامني
الذي يقول
ان تقول المراكز الصحيه ان الوضع الامني
اصبح يعني
يشكل حاجزا بالنسبه للدوا الطبيه وبالنسبه
كذلك للامداد الامداد الدوائي انا الان
يمكن ان اجري اذا كان هنالك وقت انبي
معك الوقت تفضل مع دكتور الدكتور مصعب وهو
وهو المسؤول من هذه الصيدليه الدكتور مصعب
ممكن ان تنضم الى قناه العربيه لتحدثنا عن
الوضع الصحي
وكليه المرضى الذين يصلون هذه هذه
الصيدليه اليوميه هل تلاحظ اي تغيير في
عدد المرضى بعد نشوب الاشتباكات بين قوات
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني
[موسيقى]
محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين
الناس طبعا بتعمل هروب صعبه جدا
في البلد
نتيجه لاعاده توفر الانف
هل انت شغال بصوره يوميه ولا بتستخدم
ساعات معينه في اليوم
هذه صوره يوميه
[موسيقى]
لتوفير الدوائر للمواطنين
بصوره يوميه بصوره يوميه ان شاء الله
طيب بالنسبه
لعدد المرضى يوميا يعني يعني في عدد في
تزايد في عدد المرضى هل لاحظت اي يعني
الادويه طيب مهمه قطعتها وهي شارفت على
الانتهاء والمخزون الدوائر عندك
ضعيف جدا في هذه الحقيقه بالنسبه لتوافق
الشركات
هل في اي شركات باشرت العمل في الفتره
السابقه يعني حسب علمي طيب المخزون اللي
عندكم بكفيكم كملا الى الزمن يعني على حسب
تصوره
هل في ادويه مهمه ادويه للسكر يعني تدفع
الادويه الملقيه للحياه بصوره
تمام طيب بالنسبه لانه الغرفه مصنعين
الادويه كانت او اعلنت في بيان قبل قليل
انه هنالك نهب كبير لمصانع الادويه بمنطقه
البحري واسوبا والباقيه
او ما رايك في حدوث مثلها كذا مشاكل يعني
بالنسبه للقطاع
ان شاء الله
داخل الصيدليه
الحمد لله
والخبره الاذان ان شاء الله
هو فين مع المواطنين ان شاء الله
ربنا يقدرون ان شاء الله نقدم المواطنين
نستطيع ان شاء كما تلاحظون الان ان هنالك
توافد لعدد
مقدر من المرضى داخل هذه الصيدليه
وان الطبيب والدكتور مصعب هو من يقدم
الاستشارات وان هنالك خطوره على الوضع
الامني في هذه المنطقه وفي الامداد
الدوائي بعدما نشرت غرفه مصنعين الادويه
بيان لها تقول ان هنالك عدد كبير من مصانع
الادويه
قد تعرضت بصوره كبيره منذ اندلاع الايام
الاولى
للاشتباكات بين القوات المسلحه وقوات
الدعم السريع وكذلك انها قالت ايضا حذرت
من انقطاع هذه الادويه الادويه المنقده
للحياه اذا ما استمر الحال واذا ما استمر
هذا الحال لايام اخرى وهذا ينذر بخطوره
كبيره في الوضع الصحي في البلاد والجديد
بالذكر كذلك ان الامم المتحده كانت قد
اعلنت عنها ان اكثر من 420 اصابه
منذ اندلاع الاشتباكات واكثر من
3700 700
واكثر من
3,700 اصابه في البلاد منذ احتجاج منذ
اندلاع الاشتباكات الدعم السريع الجيش
واصابات بالالاف مقداد طالما نتحدث في هذا
الاطار نبقى دائما في اطار
الادويه وكذلك اعوذ بك لو سمحت لي الى ما
كنت اوردته في نشرات سابقه عن استهداف
مركز الرومي الطبي حدثنا اكثر عن هذه
المنطقه بمعنى مع استهداف هذا المركز
هل هناك مراكز اخرى متوفره ما الذي يعنيه
كيف سيضر ذلك
بالسير العادي من يتوجه لمحاوله ايجاد
وسائل للتطبيب هل سيجد معاناه حقيقيه ام
ان هناك مراكز اخرى قد تفي بالحاجه حدثنا
اكثر عن هذه التفاصيل
[موسيقى]
نعم من واقع الحال وبطبيعه الحال ان
الاطباء الصيادله هم اللي يقومون
بالاستشارات في الحالات البارده كما
اجرينا قبل قليل مع مع دكتور مصعب
الكثير من الحالات تلجا الى الصيدليات اول
نقطه لها اما بالنسبه للحالات التي تحتاج
الى جراحه وتحتاج الى الى الى اسعاف ط
بي اكثر من المبادرات قامت في هذا الجانب
ودعت اليها كثير من المنظمات المحليه
والمنظمات العالميه الوضع الصحي في هذه
المنطقه بعد بعد ان تم تم وقوع قديمه في
مركز الرومي وهو من المراكز التي تقدم في
النص صحيه كبيره بالنسبه للحالات البارده
واستشارات في مختلف التخصصات الطبيه في
القلب
والضغط والسكري وكذلك الموجات الصوتيه
والاشعه هذا هذا
قد يؤدي الى الى الى الى الى الى الى الى
الى زياده في حجم الكارثه الصحيه
حتى افهم منك فقط هذه القذيفه التي سقطت
على اثر الاشتباكات بين الدعم
السوداني اثرت به بمعنى انها اوقفت خدمه
هذا المركز تماما
نعم هو هو قال قد اعلن انه عود الى العمل
بالامس القريب ثم بعد حدوث هذه
الاشتباكات بين قوه الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني وقعد على اثرها داخل هذا المركز
بعدها بساعات اعلن المركز انه لا يستطيع
ان يقدم الخدمات الصحيه نسبه للخطوره
الوضع الامني ونسبه
كذلك حفاظا على الكادر الطبي الذي هو ايضا
يعاني كثيرا من الوصول الى المستشفيات ولا
المرافق الصحيه هنالك مستشفى قريب في
منطقه الثوره يدعى مستشفى النوم ما زال
الى الان يقدم كلمات صحيه كبيره وهو
مستشفى حكومي ولكن هنالك عدد كبير جدا
وهنالك يعني
عدد كبير جدا من الاصابات ومن الذين
يحتاجون الى خدمات الطبيه في هذا المركز
مما يعني ان هنالك ضغط على الكاميرا الطبي
في مركز النوبه الحاره
وضحت الفكره وشكرك جزيلا شكر على كل ما
افدتنا به من معلومات وتفاصيل كذلك من ام
درمان الصحفي مقداد حسن شكرا لك
هذا مشاهدينا وكانت رصدت كاميرا العربيه
توقف كل اقسام مستشفى صداقه الصيني عدا
قسم غسيل الكلى الذي يعمل بصوره جيده ويقع
مستشفى الصداقه الصيني في منطقه قريبه
نسبيا من مناطق الاشتباك باندرمان
[موسيقى]
هذا ايضا فيما كشفت صحيفه ان الاداره
الامريكيه فشلت بعمليه الانتقال
الديمقراطي في السودان بعد ان حفزت
المنافسه بين طرفي الصراع في البلاد نتابع
عمليه التحول الديمقراطي والانتقال للحكم
المدني في السودان فشلت وانتهت بالفوضى
وبوادر حرب اهليه والسبب الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تقول صحيفه وولد جورنال الصحيفه
اعتبرت ان واشنطن اخطات في قراءه الوضع
السياسي في الخرطوم وحفزت المنافسه بين
رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني قائد الجيش
عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد قوات الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان دقلو المعروف بحمدتي
على بناء قوتيهما وتحديدا بعد تبني سياسه
اصلاح قطاع الامن في السودان بما يضمن وضع
الرجلين تحت السيطره المدنيه وهذا الامر
لم تصدقه الا واشنطن تقول الصحيفه
الامريكيه منذ الاستقلال عام
1956 شهد السودان سبعه عشره انقلاب نجحت
منها سته وحربين اهليتين وصراع اباده
جماعيه في دارفور ورغم هذا لم تقرا واشنطن
جيدا المشهد السياسي في السودان مما ادى
الى اتجاه البلاد نحو الانهيار ومعها
العمليه الديمقراطيه التي دعمتها واشنطن
منذ الاطاحه بالرئيس السابق عمر البشير
عام 2019
ابعد من ذلك فشلوا الحسابات السياسيه
للاداره الامريكيه ادى الى جذب انتباه
روسيا والصين حيث تعتبر السودان ارض الذهب
والنفط والموارد المعدنيه الاخرى وربما
لاجل كل هذه التشابات حذر الامين العام
للامم المتحده من ان الصراع في السودان قد
يبتلع المنطقه كلها محاسن حداره العربيه
نناقش كل هذه التطورات مع ضيوفنا هنا في
الاستوديو هشام سلمان الكتاب الباحث
والكاتب السياسي السوداني سيد هشام اهلا
بك معنا وكذلك من القاهره ينضم لنا الكتب
صحفي السوداني كذلك بعد قليل عادل ابراهيم
اهلا بك سيد عادل وشكرا على مشاركتنا هذا
النقاش اسمح لي ان ابدا هنا في الاستوديو
مع سيد هشام سيد هشام نتابع مع حضرتك
وكذلك مع مختلف المراقبين والمحللين
والمعنيين كذلك بتطورات في السودان كل ما
يحدث هل تعتقد بان السيناريو القادم خاصه
بعد محاوله الالتفاف امميه ودوليه للتهدئه
سناريو نحو تهدئه ونحو التصعيد
انا مفتكر انه السيناريو المتجه هو في
تهدئه من المجتمع الدولي ومن الاقليم ما
كذلك
انما داخليا الحسابات مختلفه لكن
طبعا بالنسبه انا بالنسبه لي بالنسبه
للصوره ممكن تكون واضحه لانه مثلا واخذنا
السياسه الامريكيه ما بتنبني على رد الفعل
سياسه الامريكيه في قرار صدر من الكونجرس
11/5/11 ميل القرار ده واضح
فيه تصنيف
للجيوش الموجوده في السودان في تصنيف
للدعم السريع وتصنيف واضح
وفيه
توجيه لوزير الخارجيه
انه يعمل شنو سته توجيهات سته توجيهات
يجعل من موضوع السودان اولويه في مجلس
الامن
يمنع التدخلات الاقليميه ضد
وسعره الديمقراطي والى اخره كلها هي واضحه
هي بتحرك من خلالها لانه المنفذ الغرار
الامريكي بيتحرك من خلال صناعه القرار
بتاعه ما بيرتجل امريكي صحيح ساعود لك
الامريكي ولكن حضرتك ترى بان المجتمع
الدولي باتجاه فرص نوع من انواع التجزئه
في داخل السوداني صحيح وممكن تتطور لاكثر
من كذا لاكثر خلينا نسمع ضيفنا كذلك
الاستاذ عادل استاذ عادل هل تتفق مع سيد
المؤكد ان الاتجاه للتهدئه هو الاصل
ولا يمكن ان يكون التصعيد خصوصا والتصعيد
سيقود الى كوارث ثانيه
ويضاعف المسائل التي يتحدثون الان الحرب
وتداعيات المعروفه سواء كان الحرب
فيما يتعلق بالانتقال الديمقراطي رغم ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وبريطانيا
دولتان في المجتمع الدولي بانهم الدولتان
المعبره عن الديمقراطيه الليبراليه او
التعدديه في الحرب البارده في مقابل معسكر
شرقي
غير مرتبط بالانتقال الديمقراطي ولكن رغم
ذلك لم يعرف للدولتين
يذكر من خلال الرباعيه في دفع عمليه
انتقال الديمقراطي في السودان
اللوم يقع على القوه السياسيه السودانيه
كما هو معروف اي جهد خارجي هو جهد اضافي
هو عامل مساعد
لجهود الوطنيه
سيد عادل اسمحلي بخصوص هذه النقطه لان
البعض يقول دخول جهات دوليه قد تعقد اكثر
الوضع فدخل السوداني خاصه وان لا يخفى على
حضرتك كل دوله ولها حساباتها
عن قصد ولكن الاعاقه تكون تكون عاده لان
القوه الخارجيه مهما حصلت نواياها
بتفاصيل وتعقيدات الداخل من القوه الوطنيه
والقوى الخارجيه تعتمد على بيانات وتقارير
بارده ومهما كانت فرنسا غوص في اعماق
المجتمعات ولن تغوص في نفسيات الشعوب
وبالتالي اللوم يقع على القوه السياسيه
السودانيه
السودانيه التي اطلعت بهذه المسؤوليه
وتصدت مسؤوليه الوطنيه في اداره الدوله
يجب ان ترتفع الى الى مستوى اكبر ارفع من
ذلك بكثير فانت تطلع بدورها في التصدي
لمسؤوليتها الوطنيه ولا تعتمد على القوه
الخارجيه في صياغه الوضع الداخلي في
السودان
صحيح وضحت هذه النقطه البعض سيد هشام يقول
بانه المخاوف تكمن في ان يخرج الوضع عن
السيطره خاصه بعد اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب
ان يحتد الصراع فدخل السوداني وبالتالي ان
تتدخل بعض الدول فيما يجري في السودان
بالامس كانت هناك تصريحات لمستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي قال بانه ليست هناك خطه
امريكيه حاليا لنشر قوات حوض السلام ولكن
هل تعتقد بان هذا وارد اذا ما طال الصراع
وتطور هو وارد ولكن
نسال سؤال دايما هل هل
الاجابه ولكن
نجاوب عنه هل
او السياسه الامريكيه يغلبها التوقف هذه
الحرب انا اشك في ذلك طبعا لانه
ما يغلبها ان توقف الحرب يعني هي قادره ان
كانت هناك رغبه وهي امريكيه فهي قادره على
انهاء هذه الحرب غليظه هي عصا العقوبات
سواء الشخصيه هي لا تريد انا بفتكر انها
مش لا تريد
وفي انا زيل كانه في سيناريو اخر ما هو
انت اليوم مثلا بيقول لي انا ما عندي نيه
دخل لكن ليش تنقلي كل القوات ليش توجيه
السفن نحوها بورسودان او نحو ساحل مقالات
قوات في قوات تحركت حسب نفس
بخصوص الرعايه لاجلاء الرعايه ايجار رعايه
ما بتطلب تحريك كل القوه الضاربه دي ثلاثه
وثلاثه وسته يعني في اكثر قريبه 12 الف
جندي قريبين للمنطقه ده غير الدول الثانيه
عموما هو طبعا دي كلها تدخل في باب
التكهنات لكن
بريطانيا كان نتحدث عن تخصيصها ل 1400
جندي لاجلاء بعض العشرات هذا الموضوع طرح
نقاط استفهام كذلك بالضبط هو في استفهام
كبير يعني ما انا ما ممكن عشان اخلي لي
مثلا كل الاخوان او الاجلو من الرعايه
الاجانب ولو افترضنا انه الف هل بيحتاجوا
ل 12000 انا عشان امنه اضافه يعني دي كلها
هي قراءات
في حشد وفي استخدام لكثير من
لكثير من الادوات والكروت وانا بفتكر انه
امريكا او الدول حول في دول اخرى يعني
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بعض يعني
الرباعيه عندها كروت ممكن تستخدمها وفعلا
ممكن تؤدي الى انه توقف الحرب ولو يعني
حاليا هو حصل لانه
ما بالقوه اي نعم في المجتمع المدني
الداخلي الحين المجتمع المدني قوي يعني
ولو انه نحن بنظلمهم لما نقول والله
الاحزاب السياسيه ومهما
يعني ادوات السلطه ما في يده زي اللي بيجي
هسه مثلا يحاول يحمل
الاحزاب السياسيه يقول لك والله
للمبادره ودمج الجيوش العمله الايطالي هو
اللي جاب الحرب نو انا بفتكر يعني اذا كان
المتحدث مجنون المستمع لازم يكون عاقل
بالعكس هو اذا كان هو ده الحل المتاح
وده الحل الجيد تحدثت سيد هشام فقط لضيق
الوقت واعذرني تحدثت عن شكوك بخصوص نشر
بعض القوات او استجلاب بعض القوات لداخل
السوداني سيد عادل هل ترى كضيفي بان هناك
شيء يحضر بان ربما الوسطات المبادرات
المناشدات لامكانيه التهدئه فشلت في بدايه
هذه الازمه وبالتالي هناك شيء يحضر قادر
ان يفرض
شكل من اشكال التهدئه او وقف الاقتتال
للبدء بالتفاضل ما بعد
اي محاوله
للحلول
لن تاتي ثمره ما لم تحسم هذه المعركه
العسكريه
لاحظ الطرفين
الواضح بالنسبه لي انه الجيش بما يملك من
تفوق
عسكري من ناحيه العتاد والتدريب والخبرات
سوف يحسم هذه المعركه وخاصه انها لو تعرض
الجيش
متمرده ان تكون قوات داعمه له
فسوف تهتز هيبه الجيش وسوف يهزم مستقبل
المؤسسه العسكري في السودان
اعتقد ان اي اي تهدئه او اي حلول لهذه
المساله هي الحاله الشامله يعني
يجب ان يعقب حسم هذه المعركه العسكريه
وعندها سوف تكون المنظومه العسكريه
اعتبارها احد اللاعبين اللعب اساسي فاعل
في المشهد السياسي السوداني سوف تحسم
مساله تمثيله الى الان في شقاء في مشهد
السياسي
للجلوس على طاوله التفاوض ولكن يبدو هذا
السيناريو بعيد لا نعلم تختلف لا اعني
اعني اعني ان المنظومه العسكريه وحدها
تكون هي
الموجوده كممثل
للعسكريين في مشهد السياسي لانه الى قيام
هذه الاحداث في تاريخ عسكريين
المنظومه العسكريه في الجيش قوات الدعم
السريع
والمدنين ايضا طيران ولكل تيار ظهير عسكري
محدد واضح انه القوى الاتفاق الانفاري كان
ظهيرا العسكري والدعم السريع الديمقراطيه
زي العسكري هو المنظومه العسكريه الان
عندما تحسم هذه المعركه لصالح المنظومه
العسكريه لصالح الجيش سوف يكون في المشهد
السياسي منظومه عسكريه واحده وعندها سوف
يتحول مثل السياسي ويتغير على المقاطعه
استاذ عماد اعذرني عن المقاطعه شكرا جزيل
الشكر سنبقى اكيد في متابعه هذه التطورات
وهذه التعقيدات الكاتبه الصحفي السوداني
عادل ابراهيم محمد شكرا لك وشكر كذلك لك
هنا في الاستوديو الاستاذ هشام سلمان
الكتابه الباحث والكاتب السياسي السوداني
شكرا لك
في شتى الدول الاثر اشتباكات السودان
عمليات اجلاء الرعايه على قدم وساق
الولايات المتحده اجلت 100 شخص بثلاث
مروحيات حلقت من جيبوتي مرورا باثيوبيا
وصولا الى السودان
مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه والامنيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل قال ان اكثر
من الف من رعايانا غادر السودان فرنسا
اجلت ما يقارب
538 فردا بينهم اوروبيون وافارقه اما
ايطاليا فاغلقت سفارتها في الخرطوم وطلبت
من 200 شخص ترك الاراضي السودانيه في حين
تنتظر المانيا وصول طائره رابعه للاجلاء
مع ايصال 500 شخص الى بر الامان واجلت
طائره اسبانيه 100 شخص بينهم 30 اسبانيا
وسبعون من اوروبا وامريكا اللاتينيه
وايرلندا بواقع 150 شخصا كما تم اجلاء نحو
25 نمساويا
وتسعه رومانيين وخمسه مجريين وواحد وعشرين
بلغاريا بمساعده دول اخرى
وفي تطورات اخرى اعرب رئيس مجموعه البنك
الدولي ديفيد مالباس عن شكره للعاهل
السعوديه الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز على
اسامي المملكه ومساعدتها في اجلاء منسوبيه
البنك من السودان الى المملكه
وسمى في خطاب بعثه للملك سلمان كما عبر عن
شكره لسفاره المملكه لدى جمهوريه السودان
ومنسوبيها على الرعايه والاهتمام لمنسوبيه
البنك ولعائلاتهم الذي كان له الاثر
الكبير كما قال في ظل هذه الازمه
قالت وزاره الخارجيه الالمانيه انها لا
تخطط للمزيد من رحلات الاجراء الالمانيه
من السودان مشيره الى ان اخر رحله اجلاء
من السودان الى الاردن ستنطلق مساء اليوم
واوضحت الخارجيه الالمانيه ان دولا شركه
ستتولى اجلاء المواطنين الالمان المتبقين
في السودان خلال الايام المقبله
اعلنت هيئه اركان الجيوش الفرنسيه عن
انهائها عمليات الاجلاء نحو جيبوتي وانها
ابقت على فرقاطه في بورسودان لمساعده
الامم المتحده على عمليات الاجلاء نحو جده
كما اكدت وزاره الخارجيه والدفاع الفرنسيه
في بيان مشترك ان عدد الجنسيات التي
استفادت من عمليه الاجلاء الفرنسيه ارتفع
الى 41
جنسيه
واشار البيان ايضا الى ان عمليه الاجلاء
حصلت من نقاط التجمع في الخرطوم نحو قاعده
وادي سيدنا ومن القاعده جوا الى جيبوتي
قالت قوات الدعم السريع في السودان انها
تنسخ مع البعثه الدبلوماسيه والمنظمات
الاقليميه والدوليه ما اسهم في اجلائها
الى اماكن امنه واكدت قوه الدعم السريع في
بيان انها متمسكه بالهدنه مشيره لان هذا
الالتزام نابع من مسؤوليتها الاخلاقيه
والتزامها للدول التي طالبت بتجديد الهدنه
لفتح ممرات انسانيه
هذا وكانت نشرت قوه الدعم السريع صورا
لمقاله انه تامين الشاحنات المصريه بمنطقه
جر الحره شمال الخرطوم متابع بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم نحن الان في السوق الحر
لمنطقه قريه
هذه الشاحنات طبعا شاحنات مصريه مع
اخواننا المصريين الان يعني قوات الدعم
السريع تؤمن كل هذا السوق والبترول ونحن
الان يعني حتى اخواننا المصريين معنا هنا
فنسمع منه يعني
كلمه حق يعني تجاه قوات الدعم السريع
وتامين لهم وحتى هم معانا الان يعني
متابعه مع المزيد من التفاصيل وتطورات مع
الصحفي عبد القادر بكاش من بورتسودان سيد
عبد القادر اهلا بك معنا كيف هي وتيره
النزوح باتجاه بورسودان حدثنا عن الصوره
عن التفاصيل ان كانت معك اعداد وما
الصعوبات التي يتعرض لها النازحون في
طريقهم من الخرطوم الى بورت سودان
عدد كبير من النازحين الان الى مدينه
بورسودان هم في الاصل ليسوا ناجحون بغدر
ما هم رعايه في تاريخهم للخروج بالتنسيق
مع سفاراتهم ومع القوات المسلحه السودانيه
وصلت فجر اليوم تقريبا حوالي 300
يعني عدد 300 من الاخوه الصينيين
وتايلانديين تقريبا 90 شخص
واعادات كبيره من الهنود والسوريين وعدد
من الجنسيات ويتم لاجلاء بصوره مستمره
الحمد لله منذ اليوم الاول العمليات
الاجلاء تمضي بثلاثه عاليه حتى الان ما في
اي ربطه وهناك بعض الاشخاص ليست لديهم
تنسيق مع اي من البيتات الدبلوماسيه يجري
الان معالجه اوضاعهم عبر اللجانه المختصه
واللجنه الولائيه التي تم تشكيلها لهذا
الغرض بالتنسيق مع سفير السعودي الذي يقيم
بشكل دائم ويشرف بانتظام على عمليات
الاجلاء
واس تيعاب كل الذين تقطعت بهم الشغل وليست
لديهم اي تنسيق ولكن
حضرتك تتحدث عن ان بعض الرعايه الاجانب
ليس لها او تعذر على الاقل تواصلهم مع
بلدانهم او مع
بعثاتهم دبلوماسيه وان سفير السعودي هو
الذي يتواجد على عين المكان ويدير هذا
الموضوع او يرتبه كيف ذلك نعم بعد الرعايه
وصلوا بشكل فردي دون التنسيق مع
السفاراتهم والان يبحثون التنسيق مع
سفاراتهم والاتصال مع اللجان ويتم معالجه
الامر قبل اللجنه الولائيه تم تكوينها من
حكومه ولايه البحر الاحمر في السودان
بالتنسيق مع الحكومه السعوديه التي تشرف
بشكل مباشر على مستوى السفير هنا في بور
سودان العالم جوا وبهرا تجري بصوره منتظمه
غادرت اليوم ضاريجه هنديه والان هناك
بارجه هنديه اخرى
وبارجه فرنسيه وغيرها من
البوارجات الحربيه الغربيه وايضا هناك
يعني بوافر تعمل في الخط الملاحي بين بين
السعوديه والسودان الان تلتزم في حركه
بشكل منتظم كل العربيه يشرف عليها السفير
بشكل مباشر ويتم تفويزهم بشكل مباشر
ساعود لك عبد القادر فقط اسمح لي ساعود لك
بعد الاشاره الى هذه العواجل عن الخارجيه
الامريكيه الخارجيه الامريكيه تقول ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تنسق مع شركاء
دوليين واقليميين للمساعده بمفاوضات بشان
السودان وبان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تسعى مع شركائها لتشكيل لجنه للاشراف على
مفاوضات بشان السودان اذا نذكر بهذه
العواجل كنا نتابعها اسفل الشاشه منذ قليل
اتت عن الخارجيه الامريكيه التي اكدت
التنسيق مع شركاء دولين واقليميين
للمساعده بمفاوضات كما قالت بشان السودان
وبانها تسعى كذلك مع شركائها لتشكيل لجنه
للاشراف على هذه المفاوضات الخارجيه
الفرنسيه الان كذلك وهناك اخبار وتطورات
ومواقف متابعها لحظه
الخارجيه الفرنسيه الان تقول ندعو الاطراف
السودانيه لاحترام وقف النار لتسهيل ايصال
المساعدات وتعلمون مشاهدينا بان المفروض
كانت هناك 72 ساعه هدنه تخللتها اشتباكات
لم يتوقف الاقتتال تماما ما صعب مهمه سواء
منظمات الامميه وكذلك حتى البعثه
الدبلوماسيه التي كانت تتجه نحو بورتسودان
او نحو المطارات العسكريه المؤمنه التي
كانت مجهزه
يعني
محاوله مساعده هؤلاء للخروج من السودان
الخارجيه الفرنسيه الان تقول ندعو الاطراف
السودانيه الاحترام وقف النار لتسهيل
ايصال
المساعدات تبقى عيننا على هذه العواجل
وكذلك على هذه المواقف وهذا التطورات
واعود لكم من جديد عبد القادر عبد القادر
كنت حدثني عن صعوبات ولكن انت موجود في
بورتسودان ما الذي قالوه لك خاصه اولئك
الذين
بداوا بالخروج من الخرطوم برا باتجاه بورت
سودان ساعات
تفصيلهم للوصول الى بورسودان وهناك مناطق
تتركز فيها اشتباكات ما الذي حدثوك عنه ما
الصعوبات ما الذي عاشوه طيله هذه الفتره
سلامه الملاحه البحريه حتى الان في الساحل
السوداني نعم شكرا على كل ما تفضلت به من
معلومات عبد القادر بكاش الصحفي كنت معنا
من بورس السودان ومشاهدينا نعود من جديد
الى هذه العواجل هناك استكمال لبعض
العواجل الجديده تاتي من الخارج
البريطانيه التي اكدت وصول اول مدنيين
بريطانيين الى قبرص بعد اجلائهم من
السودان نجمع 200 عليه هناك مواقف اتت من
الخارجيه الامريكيه الخارجيه الفرنسيه
والخارجيه البريطانيه بدايه الخارجيه
الامريكيه قالت انها تنسخ مع شركاء دولي
واقليميين للمساعده بمفاوضات بشان السودان
وبان هذا التنسيق هو للمساعده بمفاوضات
وبان هناك لجنه ستشكل للاشراف على هذه
المفاوضات كذلك الخارجيه الفرنسيه دعت
الاطراف الاحترام وقف النار لتسهيل ايصال
المساعدات والخ البريطانيه تتحدث عن وصول
اول مدنينا بريطانيين الى قبرص بعد
اجلائهم من السودان بدات عمليه اجلاء
الرعايه وهي تستكمل في هذه الاسنان نحن
نواكبها اما من خلال بورت سودان هناك من
ذهب برا من الخرطوم من جنوب الخرطوم الى
بورسودان وهناك كذلك من
جهزت بعض البعثات الدبلوماسيه المطارات
العسكريه التي تاكدت من تامينها ومكانتهم
من الخروج سنتابع كل ذلك ولكن سنذكر كذلك
مشاهدينا ببعض الاخبار ذات الصله وفي اخر
هذه التطورات كان افادها تقرير لصحيفه
الجاردن البريطانيه بان المنظمات الامميه
والحكومات الغربيه
صدمت من التطورات الدمويه في السودان
وانتقد خبراء موقف الحكومات والمنظمات
الامميه وعدم استعدادها للازمه التي كانت
متوقعه في اي وقت
كل الاضواء الحمراء اوضت منذره بالحرب في
السودان لكن لا الامم المتحده ولا القوى
الفاعله راى ذلك بل على العكس تماما نتيجه
رصدتها صحيفه الجاردين البريطانيه في صدمه
الدبلوماسيين الغربيين مما الت اليه
الاوضاع في السودان اللافت ان المبعوث
الاممي للسودان فولكر بيرتس رد نافيا على
استفسارات الموظفين الامميين حول وجود
تحذير مبكرا للحرب اول شيء انا وفي لقاء
مع العربيه والحدث نهايه الشهر الماضي كان
له راي اخر لم يستبعد فيه السيناريو
الاسوا هل ترى ان الحل اقرب اما المواجهه
اقرب الحل اقرب بكتير المواجهه
طبعا سيناريو ولكن مش ارجح السيناريوات
انا مازلت متفائلا فيما كان بيرت متفائلا
كانت منذ تصعيد بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريعه تحشيد وتامين للذخيره وتجنيد
وتامين وقود وامدادات حتى الطبيه وفق
الجاردن
داخليا لم تخفى تلك التحركات على الاطراف
فحاكموا اقليم دارفور مني اركو منوي حذر
في مارس الماضي من الحرب وحث الطرفين على
عدم القتال في المدن قراءات اخرى يبدو
انها اربكت المشهد فالبعض اطمئن للموقف
الامريكي الذي لم يصدر اي تحذيرات
غير ان المشهد الان معاكس تماما وصادم
والمخاوف تتعاظم من انجرار البلاد الى حرب
اهليه طاحنه
هذه التطورات مع ضيفنا من لندن الكاتب
صحفي خالد العيسر اهلا بك معنا استاذ خالد
وصحح لي اسم العائله ان كنت نطقت بطريقه
غلط شكرا على انضمامك لنا
حضرتك الاكيد انك تتابع سواء ان التصريحات
السياسيه او كذلك التفاعل داخل بريطانيا
هناك استفهامات حول اولا اجلاء الرعايه
بريطانيا وفرت عدد قال عنه البعض كبير
افاق الالف جندي بينهم 16 لواء لاجراء
الرعايه هل هناك تصريحات اضافيه تضعنا في
اطار مدى
اهتمام بريطانيا بما يحدث
تحيه لك لمشاهدكم الكرام خالد العيسر
اهلا وسهلا بك اهلا بك
بالنسبه لبريطانيا بالنسبه لبريطانيا يعني
جرى لقط كبير هنا ونغاش في الحكومه
البريطانيه وفي وسائل الاعلام حول البطء
الذي مارسته الحكومه خلال الفتره الماضيه
لعدم يعني التفاعل بالشكل المطلوب لاجلاء
اكثر من 4000 مواطن بريطاني من السودان
وهذا الامر ربما يعني
تبرر بعض الاشياء المنطقيه باعتبار ان
العدد ضخم في حدود 4000 يحتاج الى اعداد
وتكيس وهو ما تم الان وبدا هؤلاء من
السودان بالتاكيد وقد وصلت اول دفعه الى
قبرص في طريقه الى بريطانيا هناك ايضا
حديث حول عدد الجنود البريطاني الذي نشعوا
سيشاركون في هذه المهمه وهذا ايضا يقرا في
سياق العدد الكبير الذي من من المواطنين
البريطانيين في السودان وهذا يتطلب غدا
اكبر من التعامل وامكانيات اكبر من من تلك
التي ربما
من التي وفرت ولكن سيد خالد نقلت لنا
ومشكور انك نقلت لنا المشهد كما هو وتحدثت
حضرتك عن ان هناك استياء في داخل بريطاني
لتاخر بريطانيا في التعامل مع هذا الازمه
وكانها تفاجات وكانهما اوردتها الجاردن
البريطانيه دقيق بانه هناك دول غربيه
تفاجات بان ينفلت الموضوع كيف تفاجات هذه
الدول الغربيه فيما مراقبون فيما صحفيون
كذلك كانوا ينتظرون ان ينفجر الموضوع في
اي لحظه خاصه واننا نتحدث عن خلافات بين
اقوى جنرلين في داخل السوداني
بالتاكيد هناك تكهنات حتى على الوسط
السوداني حتى الذي حدث من قبل القوات
الدعم السريع كان مفاجئا لبعض المنتسبيات
الجيش الذين كانوا في في مهمه واحده
صبيحات يوم 15 ابريل بل تناول العشاء في
ذات المكان ولم يكن هناك يعني ارهاصات
تشير لانهم سيقدمون على خطوه هذه بعد
ساعات قليله بالتاكيد كان هناك احساس
بالانفجار جميع الناس حتى في السودان
يعلمون ان هناك سجال عنيف يدور خلف
الكواليس هناك مبادرات وطنيه كانت تجري
على قدم وساق منذ بدايه شهر ابريل او قبل
ذلك لاجراء بعض الصلح
وترطيب الاجواء بين المكونين العسكريين
ولكن هذا الامر لم يكن مفاجئا فقط للمجتمع
الدولي تكونات الاعلام ربما في غالبها
صحيحه ولكن هذا لا يدعو لتجهيز اي دوله لم
تجهز لم تكن هناك دوله تجهز او جهزت
بالفعل وسيله يعني اجدار اعياه من السودان
قبل هذا التاريخ
ولكن يقول البعض بانه المفروض يكون هناك
بلان بي على كل الموضوع سيكون للمتابعه
استاذه خالد اكيد باننا سنعود لك في نشرات
اخرى لمناقشه كل ذلك ساكتفي معك بهذا
القدر حتى الان لان ساعه النقاش او ساعه
التغطيه انتهت من لندن الكاتب الصحفي خالد
العاصر شكرا جزيلا لك
بهذا ناتي الى نهايه هذه الساعه مشاهدينا
ولكن التغطيه مستمره على العربيه للتطورات
في السودان بعد قليل تلقاكم زميلتي ليالي
ابقوا معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات